bonjour à tous aujourd'hui dans science
clic la gravité selon newton pourquoi
une pomme tombe tel d'un arbre vers le
bas et pourquoi la lune tourne tel
autour de la terre au xviie siècle
le mathématicien et physicien isaac
newton répond à ces deux questions par
une seule réponse la gravitation
qu'est ce que la gravitation dans
l'univers tous les corps ayant une masse
satire entre eux par exemple la lune
attire la terre et la terre attire la
lune maintenant imaginons un premier
objet à et un second objet d séparés par
une certaine distance par la gravitation
ces deux objets satire d'entre eux ainsi
à va se rapprocher de b&b va se
rapprocher de 1,6 à était plus massif
alors la force d'attraction serait plus
grande et à leur verse ci a été moins
massifs alors la force d'attraction
serait plus faible
cela vaut également pour b ensuite si
les deux corps étaient plus distants la
force d'attraction seraient plus faibles
et si c'était plus proche
la force d'attraction seraient plus
fortes ainsi l'attraction
gravitationnelle d'un objet sur un autre
père son influence lorsque les deux
objets sont très éloignées prenons
maintenant l'exemple de la pomme la
pomme possède une certaine masse et la
terre également donc la pomme attire la
terre et inversement la terre attire la
pomme c'est pour ça que la pomme et la
terre vont se rapprocher mutuellement
jusqu'à ce que la bonne touche le sol
maintenant imaginons que l'on lance la
pomme dans une direction avec une
certaine vitesse comme tout à l'heure la
pomme va être attirés vers la terre mais
elle va également se diriger dans la
direction dans laquelle on l'a lancé en
fonction de sa vitesse plus la vitesse
augmente plus la pomme tombe long si
maintenant on pouvait lancer la pomme
avec une vitesse assez élevé on se rend
compte que cette vitesse compenserait
l'attraction gravitationnelle est que la
pomme ne tomberai jamais sur terre
c'est ce qui se passe pour la lune et
c'est pour ça que la lune tourne autour
de la terre ou encore que la terre
tourne autour du soleil
[Musique]